- [Roland] All right, welcome everyone.
How's everyone doing?
(audience muttering)
All right, exciting announcements
this morning from Matt.
A lot of cool stuff going on,
so we're gonna get right into it.
This is a code talk.
My name is Roland Barcia.
I am the worldwide director
for our specialist org.
I lead all our specialist technologies
and I'm joined here by Carlos Santana.
He's gonna introduce himself,
but I'm also gonna ask him,
while you're there,
why don't you clean up a little bit?
- [Carlos] Clean up what?
- [Roland] Clean up
the kitchen over there.
- [Carlos] Oh, clean the kitchen!
- [Roland] Yeah. Yeah.
- [Carlos] Roland, you know what,
how I like to clean the
kitchen at my house.
I put salsa music with Alexa.
- [Roland] Oh!
- [Carlos] Like, oh...
(sings in foreign language)
Oh, my God.
I just like trip over the broom
with this fridge
and now there's water everywhere.
- [Roland] Oh, no.
- [Carlos] And let me, let me,
let me see if I can push
the buttons here to fix it.
No, no, no.
- [Roland] It's not working.
- [Carlos] My wife is going to kill me.
She's getting,
I'm getting,
she's getting back from a trip
and she's still going to kill me.
Like there's water everywhere.
- [Roland] Oh no!
- [Carlos] And now I have to
tell her I was dancing salsa
while brooming and kick the fridge.
- [Roland] Ay, Carlo.
- [Carlos] Ay, ay, ay, ay.
- [Roland] All right, so what do we need?
We wanna build an agent
because as people don't like
talking to the sport cases,
they take a while.
I'm like, Hey, you know what?
Instead of calling someone,
I would love to build an agent
to be able to give it some prompts
around when people like Carlos,
who's dancing salsa,
by the way, I'm Cuban
and he's Puerto Rican,
so he probably,
his dancing breaks the
refrigerator, right?
- [Carlos] I should be
dancing the reggaeton.
- [Roland] Oh, there you go.
We're gonna build an agent
and I know we have a
lot of business logic,
but it's kinda locked up
inside my existing
containerized application.
And so what are we gonna do?
This gentleman, Carlos,
who dances next to me,
is also a platform engineer,
a Kubernetes expert.
And this is just a little preview, right?
We're gonna actually
show it live in a minute.
But basically, I want to be
able to ask it some questions
around, you know, hi,
how can you help me?
There's a little bit of a preview.
You kind of see some of the tools
and existing systems that are there.
That's what we're gonna build.
And so give it a second
and then-
- [Carlos] Boom!
- [Roland] You'll see we
have things like claims,
appointment services,
account information,
all deterministic logic I built years ago.
And Carlos, who's an
exciting dancer here,
is also a Kubernetes platform engineer.
So they built all these things together
after years within a modern
microservices based system
using Kubernetes.
And so what we have a lot,
an opportunity and a challenge around
taking your existing applications,
your existing legacy applications,
and kind of exposing them
through MCP or other mechanisms.
There's different options.
And you're living now with
non-deterministic logic and
deterministic logic, right?
You have years and years of applications
that were built to be reused
and now I want to make use
of them in an agentic world.
So how we're gonna do that?
Tomorrow we have an architecture session,
or I do at six o'clock
I think at the Wynn,
where we go more on
the architecture issues
between different options
for creating MCP servers,
exposing existing applications,
different ways to do that.
But here we're just gonna
get into a very specific way.
So, you know,
exposing your existing assets
is a great way to kind of
make your existing agents
and automate things as well.
With the architecture,
we're gonna get into AgentCore.
I'm an agent developer.
I write Python.
I like to write Agents,
I don't know Kubernetes,
I don't know the existing
microservices architecture.
It could have been written
in Java or something,
I don't know.
But when you use AgentCore,
AgentCore has a lot of components,
a lot of sessions this week.
I primarily run my agents
inside of AgentCore Runtime.
I use things like AgentCore Identity
to kind of make sure I
have access to things.
I want to use AgentCore Gateway
as well so that I can
access all the nice tools
that I might have in my agentic systems.
I want to use memory to keep track
of different conversations.
So we're gonna use these components.
Not listed or new
announcements like evaluations
and the policies that
exist inside of Gateway,
won't be showing those today,
but we will kinda get
into some of the code.
And of course
EKS.
- [Carlos] EKS.
I love EKS.
- [Roland] Yes. Want to
talk a little bit about it?
- [Carlos] No, go ahead. Go ahead.
- [Roland] All right.
So with EKS,
Kubernetes is still super important.
We have one of the best
Kubernetes platforms out there
with the most instance types.
A lot of new exciting features.
Last year we had auto mode.
This year we have what's
some announcements?
- [Carlos] EKS, we have just
launched EKS Capabilities.
So that's a fully managed
Argo CD Crow and ECK.
And those bots running our AWS services.
You'll see the CRD.
So this allows platform engineering teams
to not worry about scaling or maintaining
or patching these controllers.
Some of them like the CNCF,
Argo C is part of the CNCF.
So we're taking care of
that, of that compute.
You don't have to pay for that compute.
And then, you just
concentrate on deploying
the apps with with GitHubs.
And that could be ACK or KRO to deploy.
Infrastructure.
It could be a BPC,
it could be an S3 bucket.
And that's one of the major announcements
that we did this recently.
Also, provisioning control planes,
pre-provision control planes
to allow at scale on demand,
like big clusters.
A lot of nodes.
Another one is around
EKS MCP server hosted.
So you can connect things like Kiro
or our agents in Strands, right?
To connect it to do DevOps,
agentic DevOps.
- [Roland] Awesome.
So what's the architecture
we're gonna build?
We're gonna have a simple Chat UI,
because all AI demos have a chat interface
where you prompt against it.
So, and you're gonna have
existing microservices APIs
with EKS.
We're gonna expose that
through the gateway
and use AgentCore identity
to make sure I have secure
access to these services.
And then I'm gonna deploy my
AgentCore runtime application.
I use Strands as the SDK to deploy that.
We're also gonna expose
the agent itself A2A,
which is something you can do inside of
AgentCore Runtime.
Today, it's just being
consumed by the Chat UI.
But you can envision in the future
this orchestration living
next to other orchestrations,
et cetera.
So we wanna be prepared for that as well.
And of course, we're gonna use Bedrock
to do inference in our models as well.
And so this is the architecture
and we're gonna show some
of the code with that.
Carlos,
you have a bunch of microservices.
I want to use these systems.
You told me that, you know,
I don't have to learn Kubernetes
because you're gonna just give me
some nice tools through MCP
with the code and expose
those existing systems.
So you're gonna show the audience
how we did that with code?
- [Carlos] Yep. Yeah,
because the scenario is the
our management told us like
that we have to make
everything MCP available
or our microservices
and some of these systems
have like hundreds
of microservices, right?
So if my team is going just to spend time
writing MCP servers and
wrappers and another wrapper,
like it will take us the full year.
So why not take advantage of
the MCP gateway on AgentCore?
So that's what we're going to show
on some of those microservices being used
from the EKS server,
EKS cluster.
- [Roland] Awesome.
So today, like I'm gonna play the role
of the agent developer,
I just wanna get access
to my tools and use them.
I wanna write my agents,
I wanna write prompts,
I do prompt engineering.
And Carlos, you're the
platform engineer, right?
- [Carlos] Yep.
- [Roland] And you're gonna go ahead
and take the existing systems
and make them available to me as tools.
And we're gonna do,
we're gonna do that today.
So you're gonna start with
the infrastructure, right?
- [Carlos] Yep.
- [Roland] All right.
- [Carlos] So, we'll
show you the EKS cluster.
In this case we're using
EKS Auto that we show
and some of the practices
that a lot of customers
use to deploy microservices,
they use an ingress,
they use a deployment service annotations.
Very easy to deploy these microservices
and then expose them
through a load balancer
and then use the gateway to
access that microservices.
But having a contract
and that contract comes from the Open API.
So we'll go more deeper into that.
But then the AgentCore Runtime,
we need to make sure that Roland's agent
is the only one talking to my services.
I don't want other agents around,
they are just talking to the MCP gateway.
So there's another service,
a feature from AgentCore called Identity
that will handle that token exchange
with the provider
to be able to connect to the MCP server
that actually gets created
on the fly with one URL.
- [Roland] Awesome.
One of the cool things
about AgentCore Gateway
is it can talk to existing MCP servers
and you can have semantic search.
So you can search across
hundreds and hundreds of tools
and make sure that you're
getting the tool you need.
You can also expose existing assets
like your Lambda functions.
And if you describe things
with Swagger OpenAPI spec
automatically converts
them to MCP servers.
It's not the only way.
Sometimes you use cases,
you want to code existing MCP servers,
but in this case,
I need this agent code done, right?
So as an agent developer,
I just wanna use my tools,
I wanna use Bedrock's LLMs,
I wanna write my agent runtime,
I wanna access them
and I wanna use Identity
to make sure I can access
these tools securely.
And so we're gonna combine these things
and we're gonna show some of the code
and some of the application
stuff that we've written
and then we'll actually show this live.
Hopefully, if it will work
with Demo.
So we're gonna switch
over now to the demo.
Are you ready?
- [Carlos] Yeah, let's
go a little bit of code.
Who wants to see some code?
(audience whooping)
That's why you're here
is a code talk, right?
- [Roland] Let's go.
- [Carlos] So let me
show you what we have.
Let me go to the console
and I have my home here
and let me check if my EKS cluster
is ready here.
So as you can see here,
I have an EKS cluster
and it's configure...
Let me close a few of these windows
and we're using 1.33.
And this is something so we can show like
if I want to upgrade, right,
I will do EKS Insights.
Let me, this is the new
capability that we announced.
We're getting our popup,
so this is good that it's working
and you can check it out from there.
And then EKS Auto, right?
So EKS Auto Mode is enabled,
so you can see here.
And we'll have our Compute
that is here
and these nodes are
coming from node pools.
So we are Auto Mode EKS uses
something called Karpenter.
Who uses Karpenter in their EKS clusters?
Great.
So Karpenter is the autoscaling
that automatically provisions your nodes
based on ports that are pending.
And that way you don't have to...
It's a much easier way of managing those.
What else we have here?
So it's, yeah, this is a vanilla one.
Add-ons.
I have one called External DNS.
This allows us to basically
add a domain name to my Ingress
when I create an Ingress or a service.
External DNS is part of the CNCF.
And one thing is
we recently added EKS Community Add-ons.
So things like External DNS,
cert-manager,
kube-state-metrics,
these are add-ons that gets
deployed through EKS add-ons
API.
And these are things that
you don't have to do it
through Helm chart,
container images that you have to scan,
maybe checking that the
compatibility is broken
between the version of
Kubernetes and these add-ons.
So a lot of our customers are like
now switching from
self-manage Helm charts,
deploying these EKS Communities
to deploying them through the EKS Add-ons.
And you can do that with ACK,
Cloud formation, Terraform,
anything that handles the, or
the CLI, that handles the API.
So that's our cluster here.
Oh, I can show the capabilities, right?
That we show here's the capabilities
that you can add things
like Argo CD, ACK, and KRO.
So just giving you an
overview of what we have.
And this is like me, the platform engineer
having to manage to a fleet of clusters.
So usually in a business
we have multiple EKS clusters,
pre-prod and prod
and having this in here help us a lot.
Let me show one more thing.
I think I was upgrade insights.
So as you saw it was 1.33,
but there's upgrade
insights that we give you
of like what are the things
you're ready to upgrade
or there's something warning,
or block something that will
block you from upgrading.
So that's my cluster.
So let's go to the console here to see
what are my microservices
that I'm deploying.
So I can show here an example of those
microservices on their infrastructure.
So you're going to have
access to this code.
So basically, it's going to
be divided in two sections.
One section is agent
and another section is
called infrastructure.
So Roland has been working
in the agent folder, right?
And I've been working on
the infrastructure folder.
Under infrastructure folder
we have like our manifest.
So for example, I'm using,
there's mainly two ways
or top most popular two
ways of deploying Kubernetes
resources is Kustomize and Helm.
In this case, I'm using Kustomize.
So I have here
like Roland pointed out in
the architecture, right?
Appointments, customer, and a technician.
So it has their typical deployments
with the container image
that has the the REST API
to getting the appointments,
creating appointments,
it has a service
and then it has an Ingress.
And this is what I wanted to show
that this is how you expose
how you want to expose the load balancer.
So when you create this,
it will actually create a load balancer
and this ingress points to
the service, right?
The service that I just
show here on this service
and then it will add an annotation
for the host name.
So let's look at how that
looks like in kubectl.
Who calls kubectl kube control?
Okay, I always call it kubec...
Who call it kubectl?
And who just use kube?
Okay. (laughs)
So if I do get pods,
let's see the nodes,
like how many nodes I have here.
Let me check on time
how we doing for time?
Oh, we have plenty of time.
So these are the nodes.
These nodes are provisioned
by the node group.
So if I do get,
is that a good font?
- [Roland] Can everyone see?
- [Carlos] Size or make it bigger?
- [Audience Member] Bit bigger?
- [Carlos] Okay, I can make
it a little bit bigger.
Is that okay?
- [Audience Member] Yes.
- [Carlos] Okay, so
and K, for those of you,
I think some of you raise your hand.
K is just, it's an alias to kubectl.
It's just so many years of using it
that my brain is just use K.
So we have node pools
and these are the Karpenter pools.
So, and the thing is,
Karpenter's not running as a pod in here
because it's Auto Mode.
So Karpenter is managed by the EKS service
so you don't have to install it.
No Helm charts, it just runs in Auto Mode.
And then these instances are managed
meaning that we will handle
the rotation of those AMIs.
So we're going to handle the CV patching.
So no more than 21 days
can run before is 14 days.
But we're going to take
care of rotating those.
And those are running Bottlerocket,
which is our container
rise operating system
that we recommend for
running EKS workloads
because it has a low footprint
of files and processes
that makes this more secure.
So these are the node pools
and when you have node pools
and you have pods in pending,
it will create no claims.
So you do no claims,
claims,
and then these are like the instances,
this is like Karpenter going directly
to the address Fleet API
and getting the node as fast as possible.
And then the node gets created
and then the pod gets scheduled, right?
The Kubernetes schedule puts it here.
So let's take a look of
what we have in deployments.
Well, let's show all the pods
so you can see like actually there's no,
if I do get pods-A,
there's no core DNS,
if you can see here.
Who have a standard Kubernetes cluster,
not EKS Auto?
So usually, you see things
like a CNI DaemonSet.
You see things like CoreDNS
and these are things
that are now in the node.
So these are pods that you
don't have to worry about.
So in here, we see the
External DNS that I show
and then metrics server, right?
So if you have an HPA,
like where you want to
scale this based on metrics,
the number of pods, right?
You would use an HPA,
horizontal autoscaler
and you configure this HPA saying
based on this CPU
or memory or in a custom metric.
I want to have this number of pods
and it will scale up,
scale out,
or scale in the number of pods.
So that's why matrix server is there.
Guestbook is, I was testing
the EKS capabilities
to deploy from Argo CD
that I have in a hub cluster
in a different region
deploying to this cluster.
So it's there, I was testing it,
but the thing that what
I want to show was this
three microservices that
are in the deployment thing.
So if I do get
deployments dash n
development,
we have three deployments.
So this is typically, what
our business do, right?
So when the management
team came to us saying,
"Hey, can you create MCP servers?"
We were saying,
"Well do we like wrap
this the same code again
and create an docker file
and create an MCP servers
and then I have six pods, right?"
And then we discovered
through our accounting,
for example,
are in time that AgentCore has this
capability of MP gateway.
So we don't have to code the MCP server.
We can just take these APIs,
have their documentation,
their OpenAPI schema or Swagger.
Back in the days we
used to call it Swagger.
Now OpenAPI Spec V3.
And with that information,
we can tell the MCP gateway how to access
and what are the services available
so they can reconvert it into MCP tools.
So if I want to do this in this example,
like I showed you, right?
I have the ingress here,
I can do k get ingress,
and then for the ingress usually prints
the host name
and External DNS name that
I configure in Route 53.
So usually, this is the easiest
way to configure host names
for when you create an ingress,
you put in annotation that you want to put
the domain name for this application.
So in this case I have
appointments dash development,
home insurance,
demo cloud-native-start.com.
That's just a domain name that
I have available for demos.
Then we have customer
and then we have technicians.
So let's pick up one of the microservices
and let's take a look
at what is behind it.
So if I open here and say docs,
who can tell me what is this?
Who recognize this UI?
Who have used it?
Who have used it? Okay.
So for people recording,
there's a lot of people
raising their hand by the way.
So this is a kind of the Swagger,
we just call it Swagger UI,
I guess we call it now Open Spec UI.
But these are like my microservices
and this becomes appointments.
So in the home insurance company, right,
we have appointments and
claims and customers.
So customer create a claim
based on their policy
and then if they have like a problem
that we have with the fridge is still
like running water in here on stage,
oh, my goodness!
We need someone to come in and fix it.
So we can just test it
here to see if it works.
I can just list what are the
appointments that I have,
click here,
and then execute it, right?
And then, I get all my appointments.
So this is a typical way that
our current system, right,
before Agentic,
our customer service and
everyone in the business
used to access these
APIs through another API,
another UI, standard forms.
That these are not agentic,
this is the standard way
that we have established
and we have gone through change management
every time we need to do an update.
And that's our process.
And most companies
customers have a process of that
like a change management
of anything that you deploy.
So we have this
and if we want to see the JSON,
we can click here
and we'll get our JSON.
But we can do pretty, so this is a way
of describing the REST API
as you saw all those endpoints that get,
I'm doing appointments,
so like get appointment,
create an appointment,
delete an appointment, list appointments.
So this is like the standard way
of creating this documentation.
And a lot of frameworks, right?
Spring Boot, Express js,
we're using FastAPI
have a way to generate this Swagger
or Open Spec API.
But you can also use things like Kiro.
You can ask Kiro, which are our a GenTech,
IDE, or CLI to inspect the source code
and say, "Generate me
the open swagger for this file," right?
Or get me started and start doing that.
So, but that's a requirement that we have.
And I'm going to show in a minute,
that there's something
that for MCP gateway
that is not in here.
So if I search, let me see if it's here.
I search for server.
In the spec, there's a field called server
which has a URL.
So the MCP,
we are going to give this
JSON file to the MCP gateway
to access this API
but it needs the address.
So the way to express the
location of this REST API, right?
If it's going to be
development versus production,
maybe I have two domain names
or a path base routing,
it would know how to call it.
So we're going to show the
code how would you inject that?
How we doing with that?
- [Roland] We're good, we're good.
- [Carlos] So good so far, right?
So if you have microservices,
they're up and running,
you need a Swagger file, a JSON file,
and we need to inject the URL.
So I'm going to do it with code
and then let's see how we can expose this
on the MCP gateway.
So let's go to Kiro.
I'm using the Kiro IDE.
Actually, this almost all this code
was working me Kiro back and forth
creating this code.
So he's aware of things
that are happening here.
So let me go and show you.
And this code, when you get it,
it will have a lot of test files
because I use Kiro
and as a spec-driven development,
Kiro created all these
test files to make sure
that the requirement that
I put into the beginning
was met as we developed
the this demo code.
But in this case,
I'm going to go to the MCP gateway,
Python folder, source,
and I have set up that PY.
And then I have a pipe project.
So we are using Python
to create the gateway
and this infrastructure.
But you can use whatever
other infrastructure
as to as code that you have.
Like things like ACK, in this case,
that we were talking about,
Cloud Formation, Terraform, the CLI,
whatever you have.
In this case, I'm just going to show
Boto3, right?
The Python, SDK.
So let me show go here and open the,
or I have the terminal so big
that I'm going to make
it a little bit smaller.
And pipe project
is basically like the
entry point to this thing.
So I have a entry point
called MCP gateway set up
that is going to use the
source set up dot Python code,
and the main function.
So if I run that,
just need to grab it,
go to this directory here.
I'm in that directory, right?
So if I do I see the project in there,
if I do LS source, right?
Here's all the things
that I was testing like
the different pieces to
create the MCP gateway.
But setup.py is setting
up the MCP gateway.
So if we look at the code,
I think I had it up in here,
let me find my main function.
So this little code,
and I have some motility helper functions
just to speed up things
because we don't have enough
time to cover everything.
But let me find the main function, right?
So this is the main function.
So if I run this script,
it would ask you,
you can pass two parameters.
The REST API domain name,
so you can use on when you run
this when you get back home
or tonight you can run it
and you pass a domain name.
In this case it was
cloud-native-start.com, remember?
And then, I will pass the environment.
If I'm going to deploy
the development namespace
or the production namespace.
But also a lot of customers have this,
these environments in
separate EKS cluster,
they have a pre-prod cluster
and a production cluster.
So for demo purposes,
I'm using namespaces.
So you pass those two things
and then we're going to
start using the Boto3
library to do that.
And then, the first thing that we do is
create an MCP gateway.
And to create an MCP gateway,
we need a IAM role
for the MCP gateway service, right?
That instance of the MCP gateway
is going to be have need identity,
like an IAM role
And the documentation shows that.
So I have a function
that just create IAM role
with the right IAM policy
and I get that IAM role.
The next thing that I do is get a Cognito.
So this is how I'm going to protect
the MCP gateway for Roland
when he creates the agent
and he's going to access the MCP gateway,
it's going to be an
inbound from the AgentCore,
from the agent to the MCP gateway.
So in this case,
I'm using Cognito to protect it.
So this function,
I think I have it here to the definition,
so this function basically,
it checks if I already have it created,
like for demo purposes,
if it's not, it will create it.
And then it would need things like
what is the Cognito pool,
resource server ID,
resource server name?
So this is basically,
like to handle the scope.
So if you want to read versus write,
the scopes are down here
that I want to define.
And then, basically, I create that
and I get back the information
that I need to return.
Like what is the user
pool ID, the client ID,
the client secret,
the Cognito discovery URL,
the token URL,
where you're going to get a
token from that Cognito service,
and then the resource server ID
where the scopes need to match
when you ask for a token.
So let's go back to the main
down here.
Where's the main?
Forgot the line number.
So create the MCP.
So Cognito is created,
then I'm going to create the gateway.
So there's an API
and the things that you
need to pass to this
gateway is three things.
And take into account
that you create a gateway first
and then you do your targets.
So you can create a gateway
and then with the protection that you want
and then you put,
you start adding targets.
And targets could be different
microservices, right?
One Swagger file at a time.
So you have five,
in this case have three Swagger files,
or three microservices endpoints.
I'm going to be adding
three targets into it.
So it's the information around the Cognito
and then what is the role
that gateway incident is going to use?
So it's going to run that.
The next thing is the
identity provider name.
So this is passing in
to this identity provider service
in AgentCore you saw in the slides
there's an AgentCore Identity.
So identity, think about it
like a helper for the agent
to be able to get that token.
Instead of the token
having the client secrets,
like in code or an environment variable
and doing that token exchange
from machine to machine token.
Identity can do that for me.
And it has a nice SDK that
Roland's going to show
on how the decorator
would inject that token.
What I need to create the identity, right,
to protect the MCP,
not protect the... Cognito is protecting,
the identity is a service that will handle
getting the token for the agent
but it needs to know like
where do I get it from?
Well, you're going to
get it from the Cognito
and requesting it with the proper scopes.
So this is why I'm
passing like the user URL,
the authorization endpoint,
the token endpoint.
So the identity service
is the one that is going to call Cognito
your service to get the token back.
And then, that piece of information,
there's some piece of information that
I need to pass to Roland
or Roland's team, right?
So I need to pass to it the gateway, URL.
So once you create the gateway,
even without target,
so that URL you can keep using it,
Roland would need that
when he creates this agent,
he needs that MCP URL
to use the MCP SDK to connect to it.
And he's going to show that.
And then, I need to give it
the identity provider name.
So in AgentCore you will see,
as you develop multiple
agents and MCP gateways,
you may have different identity providers.
So you need to select what is
the instance of that provider
that we just created in the script.
And then, the resource server ID is
that from the Cognito
when you ask for a scope,
for example, for that gateway,
you get a token that has the right claims,
like it's a jot token
that has the right claims.
So let's run that to see
if we can get our MCP gateway created.
So if I do UV run,
I forgot what was the command,
the script.
So I have different scripts in here.
So you can see I have like
test the gateway,
test the connection.
Oh, I'm going to show that in a minute,
creating S3 bucket to
save those JSON files.
But let's create the gateway.
So we're going to run it once
and then I'm going to run
it again with a thing.
So in this case going
to create the Cognito.
It's going to create the identity service
and it's going to create the MCP gateway
and get that information stored
in SSM parameter for Roland to use.
So in this case,
and we have emojis because
Kiro likes to put emojis
on status,
which I think is cool.
So it, yeah, and it actually describes
all these text output.
I think I like.
If I didn't have the time when I put it,
but Kiro just put it for
me so it's very useful.
And then, this is the gateway
that Roland's going to use.
So I'm going to give it to it.
So let's go to the console
and see a little bit of this.
So this is the AgentCore landing zone
or first page that you see.
And on the left,
I think this is good.
We click gateways
and we have our reinvent app
gateway that we just created.
And it has the MCP URL that
I'm going to pass to Roland.
And it has the identity, right?
The inbound identity using Cognito
and discover URL on how
it's going to be created.
So, so far so good.
So let's create the targets to
my three microservices
appointments technicians
and what's the other one, claims?
- [Roland] Claims.
- [Carlos] Claims.
So the next piece on this setup is part B,
creating the MCP gateway target.
So you can create the gateway once
and the get the target.
So in this case,
let me comment out this code
here
and then I'll run it again.
And then this would is the information
that it's going to do.
As this is running on to show the code,
I'm going to do appointments
with a description,
customer, a technician.
The claims are inside the customer.
So it's three services appointments,
customer, a technician.
And the claim information is stored
inside a customer with the policy.
It will go over each of the three targets.
It will build the URL.
Remember of the URL that was missing.
So I'm going to fetch the JSON file,
insert this URL in this function
so it's upload
and then upload it to S3 bucket.
So the MCP gateway,
the way it works is you
have to put this JSON file
in the S3 bucket
and then give the gateway the S3
location of this file
to create the target.
And then this is the API
URL that you're going to hit
the path and the bucket name.
And then you create the target
with the credential provider ARN.
So what this does is
if your REST API is protected,
which it should be protected,
most likely it should be,
it could be a parameter
or it could be an authorization, right?
Like the, or sorry, a header,
like an authorization header.
The URL to that bucket,
what I want to call the target,
a nice description for it,
and then the gateway ID to which
gateway should I attach this
target as I create the target.
So this code actually runs three times.
As you can see here,
it run three times.
It got the JSON code,
JSON Open Spec API inserted the server,
put it in S3 bucket and
created the gateway.
So, and actually, I can show
the S3 bucket should be here.
Let see if it's here.
AgentCore gateway.
Yeah.
So these are the three JSON
files that this code did.
It just grabbed that,
it created it,
it put the appointment.JSON,
customer.JSON,
technician.JSON,
and that's what I passed
when I created the target,
this location of these JSON files in here.
So this is where the JSON is located
and then the target can be created,
we'll grab it and then we expose.
So if we go to the agent gateway
here at the bottom,
I have my technician,
my customer, and my appointment.
So there's not much information,
but it says that it's ready status.
So it takes like a minute to be created.
The JSON, the S3 location
of that JSON file
and an ID, so there's not much about it
also the outbound auth details.
So this will click
and go into like how do I
authenticate to the REST API?
Let me see.
Go back to the code.
How we doing with time?
- [Roland] We're good.
- [Carlos] Okay.
And the other thing I wanted to show,
so there's the S3 bucket,
the gateway,
and then the information
I'm passing to Roland,
which is the SSM parameters
or SSM, I think it's here.
Let me open a new screen.
Here.
And then I think is parameter store
and I use parameter store
because it's configuration,
it's not like a secret.
If I had a secret,
I would store it in the in secret manager.
I'll show you a minute.
Secret manager is used.
So you have to configure IAM policies
because the identity service
is used in a client token,
a client secret.
And that secret is
stored in secret manager.
So anytime that the identity
service needs to do that,
a token exchange,
it will go to secret manager,
grab the value that is there,
get it, and then do the
token exchange with cognito.
The same thing happens
when the MCP gateway
is going to connect to your REST API
if you have like an API key, for example,
or like an authorization header
and that needs to be configured
to access this REST API.
It also is stored secure
in secret manager.
So the service has an integration,
AgentCore has an integration
with secret manager
to do that for you.
So it's a convenience way of doing that
and also providing the SDKs
to trigger from the code.
So when I run the code,
actually, this what
happened behind the scenes
when I created the target
I created an identity.
So yeah, this is the information
that I'm giving Roland.
So for example,
the most important one is the MCP URL.
So as you can see the value here
matches is a gateway.bedrock
agent US West 2.
So we are in West 2
amazonaws.com/mcp.
So Roland's going to use
the MCP client stream
streamable HTTP endpoint to connect to it
with the token when identity
gets the token back.
So it's one way.
You can have multiple
ways of interchanging
this information, right?
If it's something that if's already known,
but we did it through code
because that will make it more secure
to handle the parameter
passing and and so on.
So I show the S3 bucket
we're storing the JSON.
Oh, the secret manager.
So I showed you,
secret manager will have a few pieces
because we are also doing
the inbound identity service.
Like when somebody wants the
UI is going to talk to,
the UI is going to talk to the AgentCore.
It's not like anything can
talk to your AgentCore.
We want to protect that
connection to the agent.
So you can see here,
this is the information saved
as a API key.
It's the API key that is accessed
the service and then the
reinvent cognito here.
So I can show this, right?
This is the client secrets
and I'm going to delete this by the way,
so it doesn't matter.
And then this is the client secret.
So if you have automation
to rotate this client
secret in Cognito, right?
Maybe you generate a new one, right?
It got leaked,
then you can have some
automation that actually rotates,
goes into Cognito,
rotates the client secret for a new one,
comes back to secret manager
and you can just put it here.
And then, the next time
the identity service
needs to grab this to exchange
it for a Cognito token
to access the MCP gateway
on behalf of the agent,
it will have it there.
So the automation is there
and that's why we provide
all these services
and all of them have APIs
and we offer SDK so you can use
like CodeBuild, CodePipeline,
the CLI,
Cloud Formation,
Terraform or ACK to actually
do this rotation like plan.
Some companies have some policies, right?
Customers have some policies
in the organization
that they want to rotate
maybe like every 90 days
or every six months.
Rotate, rotate that.
So that's the integration with
secret manager.
So you will see that this information,
if you get all the details
about the identity service.
So actually, I can show that here,
that it got created.
So you can see here,
here's the
reinvent-cognito-gateway-provider.
So that is the provider
that my code created
and this is the information
that is stored behind the scenes
on how to get access to the
client secret, which is here.
I could go here and click
on it and it will go there.
So that's the integration
and the security aspect
of using Agent Identity.
And I think that's it Roland.
I have like the same parameters for you.
Okay.
- [Roland] Okay. Let's go.
- [Carlos] Let me remove my things.
So you don't need this, you need this.
You're going to create an agent
and then show us the UI.
- [Roland] We're gonna show the agent.
- [Carlos] Yep.
- [Roland] All right Carlos, thank you.
So over here, I'm inside
the agent project.
I am more of an AWS native developer.
So I use AgentCore Runtime,
which is serverless.
We're using AgentCore Gateway,
AgentCore Identity.
But the UI, I actually built
it with ECS and Fargate
because you know,
he's a Kubernetes guy, I'm not.
I'm just an agent developer.
And so, but we have a lot of our core
highly scalable business
logic on the EKS cluster.
So we're gonna over here in the code.
We're inside my project now.
For convenience, we put
it all in Carlos's laptop,
but we did this separately.
We have home insurance is my agent.
So the first thing we did is
Carlos showed talking about
loading the SSM parameters,
he already showed them.
So this is basically the code
to actually go and
retrieve the SSM parameters
to get the information I need around,
which is basically the
gateway provider name,
the gateway resource server
and the MCP URL that he showed.
So this is just basic
code that we use in AWS
to kind of go and get my parameters
from the SSM store using the APIs in AWS.
And so we do that.
So the next thing we wanna do
is we wanna show the code
around getting the MCP client
and getting the authorization token.
Now, you know, we don't
wanna store credentials,
make the state full.
So we're gonna use a decorator in Python
so that every time we go and
we create the gateway client
or we access the gateway client,
we wanna be able to get a refresh token.
So this is a good pattern to
do using a decorator pattern.
So it's gonna call the SDK
APIs to get the access token.
So each time it calls this function,
you're gonna get and get a refresh token,
which is a security best practice.
And so here you see
we're gonna get the URL
and then we're gonna use
the standard MCP client SDK
to actually create an MCP client
using a Python Lambda function.
And we are creating that
using streamable HETP client
'cause it's a remote MCP server
that's hosted by the gateway.
Get the authorization header,
which is refreshed with
the decorator each time,
some time out parameters, et cetera.
So that's the next step
that I do in my code
as an agent developer.
We have, of course, access to the model.
I believe we're using
Haiku 4.5 from Anthropic
and then this is some cleanup code around
stopping the gateway, et cetera.
So here we have part C, right?
We're gonna create the AI agent
and we're gonna make it an A2A server.
So we're gonna get kind of
the headers that we need
because we want our agent to be able
to access AWS resources like
the Gateway and Identity.
And we're gonna get your
AgentCore SDK token as well.
We're gonna get our session ID as well.
So we're gonna have a session
and we're gonna use a little
helper called Agent Context
to kinda store the session ID as well
if it's not found so.
And we're gonna check if we've
already gotten the agent,
since we're using AgentCore Runtime.
If a request comes in
and the runtime is still
up and running,
it'll just get the agent again,
we won't have to refresh.
It goes away, it'll lazily
create the agent again.
So over here we go,
we use the the agent context get agent.
If it's not there, we actually
go ahead and create it.
We start the client gateway,
we set the client gateway,
we get the list of tools and
here we have our Strands agent.
So we use the Strands SDK,
we give it the list of gateway tools
that we get from the gateway,
we give it our model,
we give it some of our system
prompts and a description
and we go ahead and
create the Strands agent
and then we wrap the strands
agent as an A2A server.
That way in the future,
if another agent wants
to invoke this agent,
that's set up
and we run that inside
of AgentCore Runtime.
So let me show you some of...
This is the first time I do
this on Carlos's machine.
And so we're gonna go and
look at AgentCore runtime.
So we've deployed this,
the code to deploy that is there as well
where we have this
home insurance agent,
which was deployed, version 41.
So we deployed this a few times.
So we have an existing
running one already.
You can see we had a two week gap.
I was traveling that week
for a customer visit.
So we have this running in our runtime,
it's a serverless runtime,
it does all the things
around observability as well
pre-built in.
So really excited about that.
We also have the UI
running in ECS Fargate,
but I'm gonna run it locally
for the demo here.
So I'm gonna go back,
move this back up here,
gonna go here,
I'm gonna, did I lose it? There we go.
I would just hopefully,
sorry, I got all of
Carlos's history there.
All right.
- [Carlos] UV run.
- [Roland] Yep. UV run.
Yep. UV run UI.
So let's go and run the UI application.
Okay.
We're good?
- [Carlos] Yeah. Local holes,
8,000, I think I have it open.
- [Roland] Yeah.
- [Carlos] Gradio, I think the Gradio one.
- [Roland] Yep. Cool.
- [Carlos] Refresh it to
see if it's connected.
Demi-Gods are inside.
Yeah, wifi Demi-gods. Whoo! (claps)
- [Roland] All right, cool.
- [Carlos] Clap everybody clap.
- [Roland] All right, there we go.
(audience clapping)
So I'm gonna say,
let's see.
What,
get your cap locks off.
I don't want... What-
- [Carlos] Yeah, like we did a-
- [Roland] Tools do you have, let's see.
- [Carlos] Yep.
So this is the video that
you saw at the beginning,
like asking like do you
have access to the tools
and they should come back with
something about appointments,
customer, right?
The three microservices.
- [Roland] Let's see.
Yep. So there you go.
Or is it the three tools,
the three different microservices,
appointment, scheduling,
technician services.
And so I'm gonna say
Carlos was
dancing
salsa.
- [Carlos] You have to be specific.
- [Roland] And
crashed into
the fridge.
- [Carlos] There's water everywhere.
There's still water
going under the fridge.
- [Roland] The water is everywhere
and buttons don't work, right?
- [Carlos] Yeah. Yeah, the buttons.
- [Roland] All right,
so this is what happens
when Carlos does salsa dancing.
Let's see what we can get.
- [Carlos] And you are
user Emily, I think.
I think she has a valid policy.
We'll see.
- [Roland] Yes.
So notice we logged in as it knew it was,
I was like perfectly,
I successfully created your claim with-
- [Carlos] Already. Okay.
- [Roland] 019.
Claim has been submitted
marked as high urgency.
Given water is everywhere,
this is definitely a high-priority issue.
Would you like me to schedule
an emergency service appointment?
- [Carlos] Yes.
- [Roland] Repair? Yes.
Please schedule that
quickly
before Carlos's
wife finds out.
See what we can get here.
- [Carlos] So it's going
from the UI to the agent,
to the MCP gateway to the EKS cluster
and back.
- [Roland] All right.
- [Carlos] And the LLM in
this in the middle, right?
The LLM this information.
- [Roland] Yeah. My agent
is sending that to the LLM.
- [Carlos] And these agents
have reasoning, right?
So it can go multiple times to the LLM
to reason about it
with multiple calls,
not just one MCP call.
- [Roland] Mm. Still processing.
Here we go.
All right, so...
- [Carlos] Have an appointment?
- [Roland] Yeah, so it says perfect,
I've got you set up
appointment time, et cetera.
- [Carlos] When?
- [Roland] David Chang.
So in two hours, December 2nd at 9:00 PM.
Pretty late technician visit.
(Carlos laughing)
Let me see
what
can I do about
Carlos'-
- [Carlos] What?
- [Roland] And saying-
- [Carlos] Why do you ask
him what to do about Carlos?
(laughs)
- [Roland] Yeah. Like, you
know, it's bad. You know?
- [Carlos] Fire him?
- [Roland] You know. I don't know.
Let's see, let's-
- [Carlos] Don't let him do salsa?
- [Roland] Yeah, don't let
him do salsa. Let's see.
- [Roland] Oh, it's, of
course I'm Emily in here.
I can hear the concerns in your question.
While I'm quite skilled at handling
refrigerator emergencies,
insurance claims, and
scheduling repair performance,
I'm afraid my expertise doesn't extend
to managing Carlos's salsa dancing habits.
It tells me repairs.
That gives me some
suggestions from the LMM.
A dance instructor.
You need one.
- [Carlos] Oh!
- [Roland] You should get a Cuban like me.
- [Carlos] Okay.
- [Roland] And then, you can
maybe get clear more space.
Maybe don't dance by your refrigerator.
Maybe some dance lessons
for you and your wife
and maybe some protective
padding around your appliances.
So some good recommendations
for you as well.
- [Carlos] That's smart, smart model.
- [Roland] So awesome.
And so I think that's kind
of the demo that we have.
We showed some of the code,
we will be putting this
in samples very shortly.
- [Carlos] Yeah, we have a slide
with the QR code that has all the things.
- [Roland] Right? So switch
back to PowerPoint and go
and so you should be back.
- [Carlos] Yeah, this is the
demo that Ron already played.
So this was our backup
if wifi didn't work.
Let me go to the next one.
- [Roland] Yeah, we didn't need the video,
which is some pretty useful.
- [Carlos] So what we
learned and resources
want to wrap it up?
- [Roland] Yeah. So, you know,
we definitely have like the ability
to expose your existing systems,
your deterministic logic,
all that great stuff.
Use MCP gateway to expose that logic.
Make sure you have security,
make sure your agents are the
only ones that can secure it
and act on behalf of the right users.
And you know,
Agentic can unlock a bunch
of modernization for you.
We do have some samples and stuff.
We'll be doing both on the EKS
side and AgentCore examples
and we'll be posting them
and we have some resources here
if you wanna take a picture.
- [Carlos] Yeah. This is
where you're going to see the,
access the resources that we mentioned
and some also useful links
and the code is there.
Yeah. Check it out it's there.
- [Roland] Yep.
And some sessions, tell your friends,
we're repeating this tomorrow
if they wanna see the code,
but also ARC314,
I'm doing that session at 5:30 tomorrow
over at the Wynn.
That session is gonna be
with another colleague
of mine named Ridula.
And she and I will talk a lot about more
the architecture
considerations and things.
You know, if you can find us in the expo,
if you wanna ask questions
since this is recorded,
we'll take questions
after we stop recording.
And then some of the
other sessions that the-
- [Carlos] The other
sessions are actually mine,
the 317 is here in
Mandalay Bay at 4:00 PM.
You can meet me again.
We're doing a hands-on
workshop on EKS MCP.
So if you're like learning about MCP,
how to use MCP EKS
to troubleshoot your EKS cluster
or analyze it, or manage it,
do DevOps with that.
- [Roland] Yep. And I'm hosting an event
for our technical field community
and some customers at the Rockhouse,
I think later at 5 or-
- [Carlos] Venetian Rockhouse, yeah.
- [Roland] Yeah. So if you wanna pass by
and ask questions and chat.
- [Carlos] Yeah, we'll
have drinks and snacks.
- [Roland] You'll find us there as well.
So thank you for coming.
- [Carlos] Thank you for-